ce n'est pas un secret le Brésilien aime
faire la fête à l'occasion de son 31ème
anniversaire le week-end dernier est
bien à lui et ses convives on fait
beaucoup de bruit dans sa villa à
Bougival comportement qui exaspère son
voisinage mais aussi le maire de la
commune alors oui le tapage nocturne est
passible d'une amende mais l'élu n'est
pas dupe on peut verbaliser et que vous
voulez vous faire face à quelqu'un qui
se fiche royalement de payer 135 euros
d'amende vu ce qu'il gagne c'est vrai
que c'est dérisoire 135 euros alors on a
des photos de la maison de Neymar alors
voilà alors ça c'est l'entrée s'il vous
plaît deux minutes je fais la visite ça
c'est l'entrée alors c'est une façade
fin 1930 bien entendu c'est une maison
qui a été rénovée entièrement vous
pouvez le voir et il n'y a pas de
vis-à-vis c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
vous promener tout nu personne ne vous
verra ça c'est la façade ensuite
regardez alors on a l'entrée voilà avec
le jardin avec des meubles de jardin
récents sachez-le et le jardinier vient
une fois par semaine pour Tallier la
haie et de tailler la haie de Neymar
également
regardez donc voilà c'est une maison
voilà alors ça c'est la vue aérienne de
la maison de Neymar il y a des voisins à
Bougival il y a des voisins envoyés ou
pas donc les voisins sont pas loin et
regardez la piste la piscine il y a une
piscine il y a une pistache voilà allez
allez
à l'intérieur
de foot
[Rires]
le salon
c'est une très mauvaise émission le
salon
à l'intérieur exactement et il y a alors
je sais pas ce que c'est ça parce que
c'est savais montrer moi la photo
les gens très riches ou un boudoir
je te dis pas donc les mecs dès qu'il
est pas bien je vais aller bouder un peu
noir voilà vous me saoulez je vais au
Boudoir j'en ai marre ici ah mais c'est
ça donc voilà donc c'est ça oui 14000 €
de loyer et elle est estimée 6 millions
cinq
niveaux il y a 5000 m² de jardin parce
que quand il est arrivé il voulait une
maison tranquille justement avec un
grand espace pour faire la fête mais le
problème c'est que ça résonne partout et
effectivement il y a eu une immense fête
notamment en septembre avec tous les
Brésiliens qui sont arrivés et là les
voisins n'en peuvent plus quoi il vient
des voitures
et sachant que l'orchival est connu pour
justement être calme un truc très calme
il s'appelle Bougival parce qu'il se il
s'éclaire à la bougie
mais Neymar il est très généreux donc il
invite toutes ses potes toute la journée
c'est des fêtes qui durent de 15h à 5h
du matin et moi ce que je comprends pas
ce qu'avec tout l'argent qu'il a il
devrait faire comme au Brésil sachet une
maison il y a pas de voisins il a les
moyens de sécher ça là il y a des
voisins juste à côté donc effectivement
après
loin du Parc des Princes attention ça
fait beaucoup tu cherches le bouton à 5
pattes non mais c'est vrai acheter des
voisins qui qui ne gueuleraient jamais
il a tellement de gens qui devrait
acheter les maisons aux environs
pour moi c'est un petit joueur
qui paye franchement c'est horrible
qu'est-ce que vous avez à dire moi je
connais bien parce que j'habitais
Bougival ah d'accord en fait
vous avez encore mal on comprend pas
excusez-moi
j'ai été soigné mais en fait j'ai passé
c'est une petite colline en fait tu te
colline et en fait tous les voix en fait
il y a beaucoup de voisins en fait donc
c'est pas du tout fait pour la fête et
en fait je comprends très bien qu'ils
sont bêtes parce que moi j'avais une
maison j'ai fait des fêtes et j'ai de
gros amandes tous les jours à cause de
mes travaux allez on est on est pressés
tu des choses sur retard
tu redescends à la station vers une
crêpe avec toi ensuite merci
c'est une belle maison mais après je
comprends voilà ce que je dis je
comprends pas pourquoi la maison là
remettez le truc derrière moi de toute
manière elle va partir en fin d'année
qu'ils attendent qu'ils soient patient
les voisins ah oui d'accord le soleil
est livré avec la maison alors les
agents immobiliers va être toujours
la piscine elle est un peu rassera
non mais des grosses bagnoles du bling
bling de je respecte pas mes voisins
j'en ai rien à je suis plein de
fric et ça m'ennuie parce que il y a
d'autres sports comme le rugby et tout
qui sont connus qui donnent des beaux
exemples le foot c'est toujours des
exemples avec des histoires de sexe
pour moi tu es jaloux et tous les jours
de footballeurs oui oui oui c'est un
footballeur vous voulez passer la finale
Valentin avec toi tu dirais pas la même
chose c'est-à-dire
merci si oui mais en terme de bling
bling en plus pour une star comme Neymar
c'est très soft 14000 € par mois pour le
coup je trouve ça très simple il
pourrait se payer un truc 10 fois 50
l'argent n'achète pas tout l'argent
n'achète pas l'éducation
par rapport à son train de vie Mathieu
si il veut acheter des plans de voiture
plein de fringues et tout quel est le
problème
j'ai travaillé des gens quand même il y
a des gens autour de lui
non mais sérieux oui il a fait deux
trois petites samba etc c'est pas grand
chose à priorer non plus c'est pas
dingue la maison est pas dingue moi je
trouve enfin je sais pas mais les deux
là-bas au bout on dirait un couple
bourré qui rentre de soirée
déconner
[Applaudissements]
ils sont complètement ébou il rentre de
soirée toute manière ce qui se passe
c'est incroyable vous aimez bien ou pas
on vous a montré la salle de bain à la
salle de bain mettez la salle de bain
avec oui oui c'est pas mal c'est le
matin
les papiers toilettes par contre et ici
on apesanteur
excusez-moi non mais c'est vrai les
toilettes sont suspendus aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je te fais couler un bidet chérie
[Rires]